hey guys welcome back to Chris Lavallee
today I'll be taking you through the
beginnings of the Roman section of the
park which actually quite similar to the
Japanese section in terms of how I
started doing it I did drop the Japanese
section for just for now since I really
wanted to move on to the Roman theme
since I started an empty sandbox again
didn't save it over the griz-lee file
thankfully and decided to just give a
couple more prototypes of the Roman
theme really spend and see what you can
really do with it and I only built one
building and then I pretty much figured
this is gonna have to be an area in the
park and that's pretty much where we are
now I want to make this area a little
bit more ambitious though than the rest
of the park and in that regard I would
say that I'm not a big fan of adding
this in the park and it doesn't seem to
be too logical within the park since
it's a much more expensive area since I
want to have a dive coaster over here as
you can see but to actually get that
dive coaster to be able to go underneath
the paths and have more terrain
differences I really need to work a lot
with scenery since there isn't any
terrain modification in the game in this
earliest alpha version so far which will
be in the next one but I don't have it
quite yet so everything that is raised
it's going to have to be scenery so this
will be a very heavy area on the scenery
and realistically if this were real life
also much more expensive than the rest
of the parks in that regard it sort of
sticks out from the rest of the park as
being a probably in the end slightly
more heavily themed although that's
something that I do want to contract
somewhat by having largely foliage
around this I do wanna create a sort of
Roman Plaza with this coaster in the
middle of it
much like the Japanese plans actually
and the major building is going to be
the station of the coaster but I do also
want to have a lot of foliage around it
now for the dive coaster itself it's a
little bit inspired by SheiKra
it's generally just a very generic type
coaster I need to give a big shout out
to code master or as a tutorial on this
channel which you should definitely
check out if you want to make a dive
coaster or any B&M really which is a
tutorial on how to actually get
realistic vertical drops as well as a
moment
and zero zeros which is actually
especially the vertical drop I had no
idea about it's really useful of course
if you want to make a dive coaster or
pretty much mandatory and from that I
really decided well it's something which
I still wanted to try and I really felt
the Roman area would be the best area to
try that in since it sort of allows for
that grid-like layout of the area which
would probably work best with having a
huge gap in the middle of it where the
dive coaster can dive underneath the
paths the main buildings are going to be
inspired by the Forum Romanum which is
the very old central plaza of Rome when
back when the Romans were still there
and it's also very much laid out in a
grid and there are all sorts of temples
and basilica's over there which is not
entirely what I want to make here
because obviously if I want to make
something really huge like that know a
theme park would be able to really
actually cover the costs for that but I
do want to make something similar and
make some buildings that are someone
inspired by it and it is going to be a
pretty empty area otherwise I didn't
decide to place any rights in this area
so far I want to keep those on the
ground and just make this sort of these
central coaster area much like I think
you do often have these paths around
dive coaster since they're just one of
the courses which you most often find
paths around just to take a look at the
coaster and have some benches where you
can sit down and things like that it's
basically more of a an area where the
coaster is almost part of the scenery
and theming and things you may want to
look at so that's really the idea behind
this I do want to play around with some
flat rides and probably it's and that's
why I quickly wanted to place the hammer
swing there but before I actually move
on to that it's probably the best idea
to actually do the buildings over here
first and make sure this area is
finished now a lot of this theme
actually spawned from having this idea
of using this piece for pillows which
actually quite coincidentally something
is something that sky storm oh it also
came up with and he actually also have
some videos on this channel about how
you can make some rad pillars but while
his are actually quite large and I
really figured wouldn't be possible in a
theme park scale obviously I wanted to
make some smaller ones see if that's
actually possible to work with them in a
theme park scale and I think these ones
actually look pretty decent and are also
really small enough and flexible enough
so long as you just place a couple
together but save them all into one well
using ctrl save them all at the same
time and duplicate them just to get a
couple pillars on the grid like this
which makes things pretty easy and it's
pretty fast to do as well but I'm
actually really happy with how the final
results is there are just a couple of
very small nitpicks that I do have to
give it's obviously impossible to
actually get the golden ratio that
classical buildings have with a grid
system like that or at least it's
practically incredibly tough to do it's
probably possible if you work with many
different buildings you get a golden
ratio in there but that I obviously
didn't want to take that effort and just
keep it on the grid and more simple to
control and also something which I did
look back at but by that time I already
made all the pillars so it's hard to
really change that is that there a
little bit then I would have liked to
make them a bit more thick than they
currently are but it's like from that's
I'm actually really happy with how it
turned out and it didn't even take too
much time to actually detail this thing
so next next thing that I obviously
wanted to do was at the architrave in
the freeze which are the horizontal roof
supporting pieces which you have all of
the decorations on the side just
underneath the roof and above the
pillars of there which is going to be
the majority really of the detailing of
this building apart from the pillows and
I had a couple of ideas about it's just
like the pillars they are pretty
unconventional like I really wanted to
use the chimneys as basis for the pillow
since they seem to be the best working
thing and I've tried a number of things
for the tops of the pillars but funnily
enough I actually think the little
decoration of the pirate's thing works
best to sort of make the Corinthian
pillars which Corinthian pillars are the
most fancy ones and the ones that you
want to have in Roman very expensive and
show-off buildings which other ones with
all the Leafs and details and the most
sort of develops of all of the
and pillows that you have which is not
that many but I wanted to at least sort
of emulate their look with the little
pirate decorations on top of the pillars
it's obviously not exactly the same and
when you look at it very closely you can
just see the pirate's theme in there but
it's really what I think it works best
from a decent distance which is probably
what this thing is going to be best to
look at from anyway and the same really
goes for the rest of the decorations on
the building I did have a lengthy fights
with these little pointy bits on the the
bottom of the roof here we took a very
long time to get in the exact position
that I wanted anybody who's tried to use
shift and control two moves to move
objects to different locations probably
know what I'm talking about because it's
it turns incredibly hard to get them
into the right positions that you want
since you have to have your Mauser
on a surface which is perpendicular to
the surface which you place the object
on for it to not suddenly rotate and get
into a completely different rotation
than you need it which makes it really
hard to get the alignment exactly right
and here on the side of the building I
just wanted to use the same little
pirate decorations as on the top of the
pillow not so much because it's a
decoration that is really realistic but
because it's the overall look color and
texture which I wanted to have because
if anything because so much of this
building is made out of just one piece
which is that one roof piece that
concrete roof each with piece which
you're supposed to use for the edges of
roofs but yeah whatever it's it's it
quickly turns into like all the same
colors and you can't really tell the
details apart so I really wanted to get
some different pieces in there which
have some slightly different textures so
it at least looks a little bit more like
you can actually see the details and
that's why I just wanted to get those
little pirate things in there even
though they don't really look that
realistic from very close up they're
more as a sort of general color and
texture that I want to use them which I
think you can definitely tell from a
larger distance they do look like some
roman mural like carvings in the wall
which is why I really wanted to go for
and also on the Forum Romanum there are
so many pillars with statues on them
which is something which I did want to
in a way puts into this part of the pike
though instead of actually having cool
Roman people on it I'm pretty much
forced to have parrots because that's
the pirate theme and really the mermaid
was way too alight to put in there and
the Pirates King was incredibly way to
light the pond there so yeah these are
not just pillars with parrots on it it's
again really something which I wanted to
go for in terms of shape and texture and
the overall look and something which if
you look closely to it it's a little bit
weird but yeah then again this general
area is much more so I would reckon than
the Japanese area and alpine area
perhaps a bit of an experiment with what
you can actually do in the game and I
have actually really happy with how it
came out I think the theme is a really
good thing to try and get different
users out of different objects that we
already have and get more used to the
building system as we have it at the
moment so which is also something that
flux drones actually said in his latest
video which is also really awesome video
but he worded it better than I actually
can but basically anything I'm really
doing in this alpha or any of the other
very early alpha versions of this game
isn't so much to make the best possible
Park but really to just try an
experiment and also get used to the
building system and that's also really
one of the reasons why I wanted to do
this theme because it's so much fun to
just work with all types of different
objects to see what little details you
can actually mix them into so that was
the main idea which went into this and
aside from the very much temple-like
structure which I have is the station
right now I also did want to put up a
wall in front of the break run at the
end there which may also function as a
good way to sort of camouflage the
transfer track if I ever get into that
but I'm not entirely sure if I really
want to but that's something I'll see
about in the future and it's also a good
way I think to make the temple come out
a little bit more but just having some
buildings which are slightly placed
behind it and a little bit lower and
also give it more of that form room
that Forum Romanum feeling to it which
it's a Plaza with a lot of temples
around it and a lot of basilica's and so
many buildings you really have that
layered feeling in the plaza which is
like so many different buildings and
temples that the plaza almost feels like
it's in some sort of valley with the
almost mountain like buildings around it
which is something that I obviously
can't get into here because it just
wouldn't be realistic for a theme park
and I'm already really pushing the
budget then a theme park here would have
but yeah I would like to experiments as
well but I sort of want to make this
facade look as grande
as I can really and make it a bit
similar to the Forum Romanum
without actually placing any really huge
building so these are mostly going to be
very flat narrow decorations this
building in particular was actually
inspired by Basilica Julia which is all
of these like very open I think it's a
marketplace that's why I remember at
least but I might have that wrong but
it's a it's a very open building with
arches all around it but since I
obviously didn't want to make a building
that large and I really just wanted to
make something which was visually
similar to it when you look from the
prawns but aside from that doesn't
really have any of the specific shape
building characteristics really I just
wanted to get a small gallery in here
with a couple of arches and a couple of
pillars and some details but aside from
that it's really just an empty husk of a
building over here and really just there
to be nice and has no other function
really and it's pretty small building
otherwise I still do want to build a
couple more structures in future
episodes but I'm not entirely sure yet
how I'll do that so I'll make them
somewhat similar to these but I
obviously do want to try slightly
different details with each building and
see if I can use different objects just
to make it mixed up a little bit but I
also don't want to build too many
buildings I'm really trying to go on the
fine line between completely overdoing
this area and really make it very well
over realistically grant I would say and
making it a realistic theme park area
which is also something which I don't
want to completely do
I do want to just kind of take well you
could say advantage is the fact that I
don't really have to care about money
over here and can just make things look
as pretty as I can basically I mean
after all it's still a fantasy in the
game and this is still early alpha and
also I wanted to have this small area in
between the parts not just seem like one
big rocket pit which is something that
I'm a would wanted to do but since I
don't have too many buildings around
this Plaza I wanted to have the area
underneath the path sort of contribute
to a more urban style to the entire area
so instead of having rocks around the
paths I also wanted to have some very
small hidden facades and some windows
and building like structures underneath
the paths as well which was a bit of
just a random thing I felt like doing
really bunny and I am quite happy with
how it works and it definitely makes it
all feel a lot more like it's it's one
hole like I really feel if I had rocks
over here as well and then actually had
just buildings above the paths you would
really see that big contrast between
just rocks and foliage underneath the
paths and buildings above the paths and
now it just feels more like it's all
part of one multi-layered maybe a
hillside structure with different
buildings at different heights basically
that type of idea which is what I want
to go for obviously Rome as well was
built on a hill so that's maybe a bit of
an inspiration for it as well the
biggest difference that I would probably
know it's between this and what it's
inspired by though is that I didn't want
to add a lot more foliage and leave more
room open without buildings and be able
to actually get some trees and bushes
and flowers in there rather than filling
everything with buildings because one of
the things which I've already sort of
feared at this point was that every but
everything would end up looking similar
even though I have these different
little details and wall textures in
there and there is still some contrast
within the buildings they are very light
generally and that's something which I
did try to counteract there by ending
the brick walls where if I could really
as details or arches but it's something
which is really hard to fight with the
which I pretty much needed to use to
actually get this structure to be like
this and even looking back I think it
may be a little bit too much on the
light side like it's I do like how light
it is
it's it's definitely got an aesthetic
look to it but I sort of want the
foliage to counteract that very light
color of the buildings and I've really
feared if I would just have buildings
around everywhere it would not just be
extensively over the top but also be
very hard to really tell them apart and
it'd be one big sea of marble pillars
which well it's definitely something
that the original Forum Romanum looked
like in the end it's not something that
I really want to make in this context
just want to have more foliage and
gardens around here with the occasional
Roman buildings and a couple of lanterns
which are hanging by some stone pillars
I'm not really sure about them I really
hope at some point in the future and
definitely sort of do expect it as well
to get some more generic lamps which you
can use to you make different lamps but
much like people always did in
rollercoaster country by combining the
already available lamps with different
custom scenery pieces for different
lamps it's already quite a lot of fun to
actually combine different scenery
pieces to make some almost custom lamps
really which is something which I didn't
want to do there but really would have
loved to have some more modern lamps in
there though that's just wishful
thinking I do have to say I do complain
quite a lot about things that are not in
the game and I am definitely aware that
this is an alpha and that's just the
kind of stuff that I like to talk about
in these random screen screams what
streams of consciousness that the
time-lapse commentary is pretty much are
but yeah that's it for this time-lapse
though I do still have a small real-time
point so this is what the area currently
looks like plus a couple of trees which
I added to make the thumbnail a nice
honor to keep in there otherwise the
thumbnail would be pretty clickbait ish
but yeah what you see is what you can
really hear there are a couple of things
which I should really say though it's
definitely rough around the edges still
need to add some more scattered details
around here to make it feel a little bit
more alive like some small barrels here
and there and
you know that the good old random stuff
that you can just scatter around to have
some extra detail on make areas feel a
little bit more alive it's basically the
bare bones and the spine structure
really of the plaza which I have at the
moment and there are definitely some
other things which I want to add I still
want to get some sort of queue going
over here I run through the forest there
so that's why I'm need to remove the
trees again to actually be able to get
the rockwork underneath it and actually
position them pretty well instead of
just having them float around and also I
think some buildings over here but I'm
not quite sure and probably a building
over here as well and where you go down
here I may want to also extend the Roman
area a little bit at some more normal
houses rather than big villas or temples
or things like that and maybe also a
triumphal arch which is something which
I may want to do because it's just a
really cool idea I think and I've tried
a couple of things with it and I think
it may actually turn out very pretty in
the end but yeah this is what I have at
the moment so thank you guys for
watching I'll pick it up next time so
see you guys then